この手のおもちゃ、皆さんよく見ると思うんですよ
こうなんか、
この子に話しかけます・・・
『こんにちは』って言ったら、
『コンニチハ（高音）』
ってマネするおもちゃ、よくあると思うんですけども
たまたまおもちゃ屋さんに行って、これ見つけて
話しかけた時の、この子の動きが
かなりヤバかったです！！！
開けてみます！
とりあえず動きを見てほしい、動きを。
めっちゃくちゃ見た目はカワイイですね
こんな愛くるしいのに、これ
マジぶっ壊れですからね
（謎の声を発するうさぎ）
いや俺なんも言ってないけど・・・
マネするうさぎ：『いや俺なんも言ってないけど』
ﾌﾌｯ...（笑い）
うさぎ：『ﾌﾌｯ...』
あはは
うさぎ：『あはは』
あはははは・・・
うさぎ『あはははは・・・』
ｯはっはっは・・・
うさぎ『はっはっは』
はっはっはっは！！
うさ『はっはっは！！』
はっはっはっはっはっ！！！！！
うさ『はっはっはっ はっはっは！！！』
お前ふざけんなよ！
はい、という感じでございます。
うさ『はい、という感じでございます。』
けっこう激しくないですか？
うさ『けっこう激しくないですか？』
いや激しいよね
うさ『激しいよね』
おまえ何でもマネすんじゃねぇ！！
何秒間マネするのか、ちょっと数えてみましょう。
あ～～～・・・
うさ『あ～～～』
うるせぇわ！
ｷｭｷｭｷｭｷｭｷｭｷｭ､ｷｮｰｩ!
うさ『ｷｭｷｭｷｭｷｭｷｭｷｭ､ｷｮｰｩ!』
ﾌﾞﾗｧ-!!
うさ『ﾌﾞﾗｧｰ!!』
ﾌﾞｩﾗｧｱｰ!!!
うさ『ﾌﾞｩﾗｧｱｰ!!!』
ﾌﾞｩrrrﾗｧｰｰｰｯ!!!!
うさ『ﾌﾞｩrrrﾗｧｰｰｰｯ!!!!』
えぇ！？
うさ『えぇ！？』
ぉえぇ！？｜うさ『ぉえぇ！？
ぅえ゛ぇ！！？？
うさ『ぅえ゛ぇ！！？？』
ぴえぇえ！！？？
うさ『ぴえ゛ぇえ゛！！？？』
ﾌﾟﾙrrrrrrrr
うさ『ﾌﾞﾙrrrrrrr』
おまえおもしろいなマジで
はぁっ、ダメだツボる。
はい、というわけで
12個買いました！
さっそく全部開封していきましょう
うさ『さっそく全部開封していきましょう』
マネすんなや
はいというわけで12個全部でました
1匹でもけっこう、
この首の振りが激しかったんですけど
12個だとどれくらいの威力になるのか、ちょっと電源をつけていきましょう
（うさぎを置く音）
（その音をマネするうさぎ）
（さらにマネするうさぎたち）
（騒ぐうさぎたち）
静かにしろぉおおおお！！！！
まってまってまって
（うさぎ大合唱）
あ～～～～～～
物音に反応しちゃうんで
もうこいつらを置くときに音をたててはいけないということが分かりました
次は頑張って物音たてずに置いていきます
こ～んに～ちは～～～～
こ～んに～ちは～～～～ｲﾔｯﾍｰｲ！！
うさぎたち『こ～んに～ちは～』
うさぎたち『こ～んに～ちは～ｲﾔｯﾍｰ』
（一瞬だけマネするうさぎ）
（その一瞬をさらにマネするうさぎたち）
（連鎖するうさぎたち）
あぁ、いいよいいよ
『あ。』じゃねぇよ
おー、そこいける？
うさ『おー、そこいける？』
二人ならできるんですね
うさ『二人ならできるんですね』
ってことはこれ三人もひょっとしたら？
できるかもしれませんね
こーんにーちは！
うさ『こーんにーちは！』
すごい！
うさ『すごい！』
三人でもー？
うさ『三人でもー？』
できた！！
（一瞬だけマネするサイドうさぎ）
（それをマネするセンターうさぎ）
（連鎖）
はっはっはっはっはっはっはっはっはー！
うさぎたち『はっはっはっはっはっはっはっはっはー！』
（時間差でマネするうさぎたち）
はっはっはっはっは・・・
うさぎたち『はっはっは』
（バラバラにマネするうさぎたち）
な！おまえら
ふっふ
うさぎたち『ふっふ』
はははははは
うさぎたち『はははははは』
（よくわからないマネを始めるうさぎ）
（連鎖）
♬～エンディング